if someone walks up to you on the street
and says alright I have a challenge for
you I want you to construct a triangle
that has sides that have sides of length
two so sides of length let me write this
a little bit neater sides of length two
two and five can you do this let's try
to do it and we'll start with the
longest side the side of length five so
the side of length five that's that side
right over there and now let's try to
draw the sides of length two every side
of the triangle obviously connects with
every other side so that's one side of
length two and then this is another side
of length two another side of length two
and you might say fine these aren't
touching right now these two points in
order to make a triangle we have to
touch them so let me move them closer to
each other but we have to remember we
have to keep these side lengths the same
and we have to keep touching the side of
length five at its endpoint so we could
try to move them in we could try to move
them in but what's going to happen well
you could rotate them all the way down
and they're still not going to touch
because two plus two is still not equal
to five if they rotate all the way down
they're still going to be one apart so
you cannot construct this triangle you
cannot construct this triangle and I
think you're noticing a property of
triangles to the longest side cannot be
longer than the sum of the other two
sides here the sum of the other two
sides is four two plus two is four and
the other side is longer and even if the
other side was exactly equal to the sum
of the other two sides you're going to
have a degenerate triangle let me draw
that so this would be sides say two two
and four so let's draw the side of
length four side of length four side of
length four let me draw it a little bit
shorter so that's your side of length
four and then in order to make the two
sides of length two touch in order to
make them touch you have to rotate them
all the way inward you have to rotate
them all the way inward so that both
this angle and this angle essentially
have to be
zero degrees and so your resulting
triangle if you rotate this one all the
way in and you rotate this all the way
the points will actually touch but this
triangle will have no area anymore this
will become a degenerate degenerate
triangle and it really looks more like a
line segment so let me write that down
this is a degenerate in order for you to
draw a non degenerate triangle the sum
of the other two sides have to be longer
than the longest side so for example you
could definitely draw a triangle with
sides of length three three and five so
if that's the side of length five and
then this if you were to rotate all the
way and those two points would if you
were to rotate all the way in if you
were to rotate let me draw this a little
bit neater so let's say that's where
they connect and we know that we could
do that because if you think about if
you were to keep rotating these they're
going to have to pass each other at some
point they're going to have to overlap
if they were if you tried to make a
degenerate triangle these points
wouldn't touch they'd actually overlap
by one unit right over here so you could
rotate them out and actually form a non
degenerate triangle so this one you
absolutely could and then there's
another interesting question is this the
only triangle that you could construct
that has sides of length three three and
five
well you can't change this length you
can't so you can't change that point in
that point and then you can't change
these two lengths so the only place
where they will be able to touch each
other is going to be right over there so
this right over here is the only
triangle that meets those constraints
you could rotate it in whatever else but
if you rotate this it's still the same
triangle this is the only triangle that
has sides of like three three and five
you can't change any of the angle
somehow to get a different triangle